the decision to to say like we'll keep
up legal speech and take down illegal
speech or criminal speech these are not
like binary choices someone has to
decide what falls into the category of
legal and illegal speech and that is
often decisions that like that the
government makes and then in tells the
tells the platforms to enforce and so
like these kinds of conversations it was
unclear how any of these were going to
take place in light of this decision
because it was so over Brad uh comment
from the government decided that me
saying to Governor de santis that
toddler masking made no sense was
illegal speech that's how YouTube
decides to take down a video of me
talking to a sitting governor of Florida
uh if a government that is prohibited
from doing that by the Missouri V Biden
case that is a win for free speech it's
not a subtle win it's a real actual win
the government abused this ambiguity
that Kate is talking about in order to
suppress your speech do we really want
that